wir werden dich vergiften du wirst
langsam und qualvoll sterben das ist
eine drogen die bekamen die bautzener
stadträtin annalena schmid letztes jahr
per anonymen telefonanruf
damit ist sie nicht allein sie ist eine
von vielen politikerinnen und politikern
im ganzen land die angegriffen bedroht
werden weil sie politik machen
das geht wirklich quer durch alle
politischen lager also nicht nur eine
partei ist betroffen sondern eigentlich
alle von links bis nach rechts frau
schmidt ist zwar parteilos aber sie
sitzen in bautzen für die grünen im
stadtrat und ist mir jetzt in dresden
zugeschaltet hallo frau schmidt einen
guten abend als wir diesen anruf bekam
letztes jahr
was haben sie da gedacht ich habe in dem
moment erstmal rillen relativ wenig
gedacht sondern ich war in der kneipe
mit freundin und habe anonymen anruf
bekommen als ich gerade rausging
rauchten ging dran und bekam dann diese
worte zu hören
ich habe dann die zigarette fertig
geraucht bin reingegangen habe das den
anderen erzählt und war eigentlich erst
am nächsten tag geschaut so richtig
geschockt darüber und hab dann
entsprechend anzeige erstattet und was
aus der anzeige geworden es ist so dass
die polizei das sehr ernst genommen hat
ebenso die staatsanwaltschaft allerdings
habe ich drei monate nach dem vorfall
die einstellungsverfügung zugeschickt
bekommen man hat herausgefunden dass der
anruf von einer telefonzellen bautzen
kam aber die täter konnten nicht
ermittelt werden gab es danach noch mal
irgendwas so was in die richtung immer
wieder allerdings sehe ich mittlerweile
davon ab anzuzeigen
da gehen wir doch noch mal drauf ein
denn das ist noch etwas was haben sie
uns in einem interview gesagt und dieses
interview haben wir genutzt um ein
kleines porträt über sie zu erstellen
das hat der kollege stefan kalt gemacht
er kritisiere meint anna lena schmidt
der müsse sich auch engagieren
das kann die gebürtige hessin nun im neu
gewählten stadtrat von bautzen sie ist
parteilos für die grünen eingezogen in
die politik geraten ist sie durch diese
vorfälle
sie liegen etwa vier jahre zurück junge
ausländer hatten wochenlang auf dem
kornmarkt bautzener bürger angepöbelt
daraufhin jagte neonazis die
asylsuchenden durch die stadt und
annalena schmid das hat ihr leben
verändert weil es mich dann schon zum
einen die situation an sich sehr
schockiert hat dass ich als frau im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert weil ich
einem abend zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort war
mit den aus sicht der rechtsextremen
falschen menschen dort stand und dann
mit vor rechtsextremen wegrennen musste
dann war ich einfach schockiert wie eine
stadtgesellschaft wie die polizei darauf
reagiert was in pressekonferenzen
artikuliert wird usw
die junge frau betreibt inzwischen ein
sehr bekanntes online tagebuch darin
dokumentiert und kommentiert sie das
konfliktreiche bautzener klima
schonungslos unverhohlener hass schlägt
ihr zuweilen entgegen der maria und
martha kirche zb findet eine
veranstaltung statt unter dem motto
zurück zur sachlichkeit aber das krasse
gegenteil tritt ein unter beifall wird
sie auf dem podium beschimpft
[Applaus]
relativ wenig ging mir durch den kopf
ich dachte nur daran ok jetzt ist der
punkt wo ich an bringen kann dass ich
gut für bautzen bin
dieser meinung ist sie bis heute die
liebe diese stadt daran ändern auch
morddrohungen nichts
sie anzuzeigen lässt sie inzwischen es
führe zu nichts
sie versucht damit zu leben dann macht
das was mit einem aber ich muss sagen
dann habe ich einfach noch die hoffnung
dass die leute sich dann doch nicht an
mich ran trauen
ich hoffe also ich rede mir ist ein um
keine angst zu haben und ich hoffe dass
es irgendwie nicht naiv ist und ich dann
irgendwann das gegenteil erleben muss
vor vier jahren kam sie als
wissenschaftlerin nach bautzen wie sehr
sich ihr leben verändern würde hätte
sich die historikerin nicht träumen
lassen und tatsächlich es ist alles
andere als ein traum ja gar nicht so
einfach für kommunalpolitiker in
deutschland zurzeit frau schmidt als sie
angefangen haben mit der politik war ihm
klar dass sie da so zur zielscheibe
werden könnten
ja und nein ich habe natürlich in der
situation angefangen politik zu machen
als ich schon von bedrohungen betroffen
war
ich habe in diesem jahr in einen im
letzten jahr wir haben 2020 in den
letzten jahr erst so richtig aktiv
angefangen kommunaler politik zu machen
ich war allerdings vorher schon
bedrohungssituationen ausgesetzt das hat
sich allerdings sehr verstärkt in der
phase vor allem als sich für die
kommunalpolitik kandidiert habe das ging
in der phase ja sogar so weit dass
rechte demonstrationen gegen mich
angemeldet haben und so geschichten und
deshalb war ich eigentlich schon darauf
vorbereitet was dann so kommen wird das
heißt wenn jemand eine demonstration
gegen sie anmeldet dann kann man ja
relativ einfach herausfinden wer diese
person ist das ist eine frage die hat
uns agnes johanna von schlägern auf
facebook gestellt die wollten nämlich
wissen ja sind diese drohungen anonym
oder ich habe weiter die frage mal
bürger wissen sie
werder versucht gegen sie vorzugehen ja
und nein also wenn ich auf facebook
bedrohungen bekomme beleidigungen etc
dann steht dort natürlichen namen dabei
der fall mit der morddrohung der young
geführt wurde ist da ist es so dass wie
ich schon gesagt habe da kam anonym
per telefon man hat herausgefunden dass
er von einer telefonzelle in bautzen
kamen
das heißt dort kann ich nicht genau
sagen wer es war nur das ist ausbau zu
kann und die demonstration da können sie
herausfinden wer die angemeldet hat
genau das war ein ehemaliger npd politik
und der hat zusammen mit ehemaligen fdp
politikern die die ganze entsprechende
sache angemeldet welche aus bei anderen
dingen weiß ich eben nicht so genau ja
also es ist so eine gemischte
gefahrenlage sage ich mal
welche auswirkungen hat das ganze denn
jetzt auf ihren alltag auf ihr leben
drehen sie sich mal öfter auf der straße
um oder gehen sie gar nicht mehr alleine
vor die tür oder meiden sie bestimmte
gebiete weil sie wissen da könnte jemand
auf mich lauern ich weiß nicht ob sie
mich erst noch hören
jetzt höre ich sie wie geht das war
meine frage war welche auswirkungen das
ganze so auf ihr leben und ihren alltag
hat also gibt es da bestimmte gebiete
die sie meiden oder gehen sie nicht mehr
alleine vor die tür oder abends nicht
mehr vor die tür
man versucht das natürlich an das eigene
leben gar nicht so sehr herankommen zu
lassen allerdings hat es natürlich die
auswirkungen dass man zb in einem
supermarkt nicht mehr einkaufen geht
wenn das ein supermarkt ist wo man
permanent angepöbelt und beleidigt wird
wenn man den supermarkt betrifft weil
dort eine bushaltestelle davor ist wo
immer menschen setzen
ich versuche bestimmte wege nicht mehr
in der stadt zu gehen weil ich genau
weiß dass ich dort bestimmte jugendliche
aufhalten wo man dann auch im alltag in
der stadt entsprechenden beleidigungen
und bedrohungen ausgesetzt ist
allerdings ist es für mich auch ganz
klar dass ich das mein leben nicht
dahingehend ändern werde dass ich zum
beispiel die stadt verlassen denn das
ist ein problem an der kommunalpolitik
kommunalpolitikerinnen und
kommunalpolitiker
müssen zumindest jetzt im stadtrat
bautzen und in sachsen insgesamt sieht
in anderen bundesländern bestimmt
ähnlich aus ebenso dass man den
erstwohnsitz in der stadt haben muss wo
man stadträtin ist so dass man auch gar
nicht so sehr der ganzen situation
entfliehen kann
das ist eine frage die kam auch auf
jetzt im vorhinein die hat stefan kauf
twitter gestellt ob sie schon mal ans
aufgeben gedacht haben und wenn ja was
hat sie davon bis man abgehalten oder
mal anders gefragt andere sorgen einfach
sorry brauche ich nicht in meinem leben
ich hierauf haben wir gerade gesehen
warum machen sie das nicht
natürlich ich habe schon mehr als einmal
ans aufhören gedacht
ich hatte ja schon gesagt ich bin erst
2019 in den stadtrat gewählt worden und
habe das für mich auch so ein bisschen
als entscheidung genommen bleibe oder
gehe ich wäre ich nicht in den stadtrat
gewählt worden wäre ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile schon
gegangen
ich finde es aber unglaublich wichtig
für die demokratie dass sich menschen
dann nicht davon abhalten lassen denn in
die politik zu gehen sich weiter zu
engagieren das betrifft ja nicht nur
politikerinnen und politiker sondern
auch menschen die sich für geflüchtete
einsetzen die sich für seenotrettung
einsetzen und so weiter und ich glaube
wenn all die menschen die da grund der
situation oder eben der kommunalpolitik
bedrohung ausgesetzt sind würde das
miteinander in deutschland noch deutlich
trauriger aussehen
und wenn sich die menschen die von
antidemokraten bedroht werden abhalten
lassen in die kommunalpolitik
landespolitik bundespolitik zu gehen das
ist aus meiner sicht eine ganz große
gefahr für unsere demokratie
ich selbst habe mich sehr viele jahre
meines lebens mit dem
nationalsozialismus und vor allem der
show also dem holocaust auseinander
gesetzt und ich glaube das hat mich tief
beeindruckt und hat in mir das so
verstärkt ist einfach nie wieder
passieren davon da können wir alle was
tun sei es in der kleinen
kommunalpolitik oder eben auf höheren
ebenen und ich glaube dass einfach die
angst um die demokratie mich dazu bewegt
da einfach weiterzumachen
das soll tatsächlich eine frage die auch
schon gestellt wurde was treibt sie an
das sind werte die ihnen wichtig sind
die gucken mal kurz die in die
kommentare auf youtube da gibt es so ein
bisschen hin und her ob jetzt auch nur
linke politiker angegriffen werden oder
auch politiker der afd
wir ganz klar sagen nein das geht durch
alle lager auch politiker der afg werden
bedroht und angegriffen da gab es ja
auch einen prominenten fall in bremen
allerdings haben wir auch kommen wir
gleich mal drauf sind die zahlen da doch
eindeutig das ist oft auch er aus dem
rechten lager gegen linke oder
vermeintliche linke politiker geht dann
ganz noch hier die fragen was mit
angriffen der sogenannten flüchtlinge
auf diejenigen ist die schon länger hier
leben das ist eine ganz klare worte
braucht ist ein versuch also ein
ablenkungsversuch war darum geht es hier
überhaupt nicht grad nochmal unser
kommentar formular wo die kollegin mir
was rein geschrieben hat carolin
ellenberger schreibt ich möchte sie
umarmen post mit die anderen fragen
können wir gleich mal glaube ich besser
machen weil vielleicht schauen wir uns
erstmal an tatsächlich was ist noch so
an fällen gibt und und tatsächlich die
zahlen die wir gerade schon kurz
angesprochen haben da hat mein kollege
antworten kurschilgen mal ein bisschen
gesammelt 15 januar 2020 anschlag auf
das büro des bundestagsabgeordneten
karamba diaby in halle an der saale ein
unbekannter schießt mehrfach auf eine
fensterscheibe verletzt wird niemand
doch der schock sitzt tief
also ich bin fassungslos und finde dass
gewalt ist keine mittel einfach um seine
ziele zu erreichen ich kämpfe dafür dass
wir zusammenhalten und da lasse ich mich
nicht ein schichten von einer minderheit
der andere meinung ist
karamba diaby ist kein einzelfall in den
vergangenen monaten berichten zahlreiche
politiker von bedrohungen und
anfeindungen sowie die sächsische
landtagsabgeordnete juliane nagel
sie machte am wochenende einen drohbrief
öffentlich an den galgen mit dir oder
standrechtlich erschossen so die
drastische botschaft nagel hatte den
polizeieinsatz in der silvesternacht im
leipziger stadtteil connewitz als
rabiates vorgehen bezeichnet
seitdem hätten die anfeindungen stark
zugenommen
auch er erhielt morddrohungen an stalker
bürgermeister von es dorf in
niedersachsen
er engagierte sich für flüchtlinge die
anfeindungen kamen offenbar von
rechtsextremisten mit hakenkreuzen an
meinem pkw oder auch entsprechenden
beleidigenden zetteln in meinem
briefkasten nur mehr mit der vergasung
analog der antifa gedroht wird oder eben
auch gesagt wird ich sei doch zu den
ziegen kickern gehen
inzwischen ist er als bürgermeister
zurückgetreten aus angst ihm könne etwas
passieren nur geändert hat das nichts
focke wird immer noch bedroht so wie
viele seiner kollegen 2009 10 gab es
1241 straftaten gegen politiker ähnlich
viele wie im jahr davor um den
straftaten die sich eindeutig zuordnen
lassen wurden mehr als 60 prozent von
rechtsextremen verübt sowie wohl auch
der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
angriffe auf kommunalpolitiker haben
letztes jahr sogar zugenommen
das zeigt eine umfrage unter 1.000
bürgermeistern in deutschland acht
prozent aller kommunen gaben an dass
mitarbeiter opfer einer straftat wurden
einer davor waren es nur sechs prozent
der innenminister sieht akuten
handlungsbedarf angriffe
gewaltandrohungen und anfeindungen gegen
politiker sind eine erhebliche gefahr
für unser demokratisches miteinander so
horst seehofer um kommunalpolitiker
besser zu schützen will die
bundesregierung paragraf 188 des
strafgesetzbuchs ändern
bislang schützt das gesetz bundes und
landespolitiker vor übler nachrede und
verleumdung nun soll der paragraf auch
kommunalpolitiker mit einschließen
in besonders konkreten bedrohungslage
können kommunalpolitiker unter
polizeischutz gestellt werden
jüngstes beispiel ist der bürgermeister
von kamp-lintfort christoph landscheidt
tja also ganz schön schwieriges thema
hier gibt's auch einen kommentar auf
facebook von agata fastnacht die
schreite ist es traurig dass es so einen
hass auf menschen gibt die sich in der
politik engagieren zivilcourage ist
wichtig aber deprimierend und einer mit
der ich darüber spreche die davon
betroffen ist es allerdings mit
stadträtin für die grünen in bautzen
wird auch immer wieder bedroht und
angefeindet seitdem sie dieses amt inne
hat aber auch schon davor jetzt haben
wir gerade gesehen der bürgermeister der
stadt kamp lintfort der wird unter
polizeischutz gestellt weil er bedroht
wurde ist es auch was worüber sie schon
nachgedacht haben ich habe selbst
darüber nicht nachgedacht weil das
natürlich ein instrument ist was die
polizei die sicherheitsbehörden einem
anbieten müssen
ich war mal in einem gespräch mit einem
staatsschutz beamten der auch darüber
aber mehr so seine witze gemacht hat und
dass da noch nachgelegt hat dass man
mich auch in schutzhaft nehmen könnte
und das war für mich so ein punkt wo ich
gedacht habe oder mir die frage gestellt
ob ich auch weiterhin anzeigen möchte
wenn es teilweise auch von beamtinnen
und beamten eher lustig gemacht wird und
deshalb kann ich mir das im moment nicht
vorstellen dass ich mich unter
polizeischutz sicherer fühlen werden ist
das eine erfahrung die sie öfter machen
dass polizisten oder die polizei sie
nicht ernst nehmen nein das war jetzt
ein fall und es kommt sehr darauf an
welchen beamten welche beamten man gerät
genau wie bei den staatsanwälten
staatsanwältinnen auch da gibt es den
einen oder die andere die das vielleicht
nicht entsprechend ernst nimmt oder sich
nicht schon wieder damit
auseinandersetzen möchte
allerdings habe ich insgesamt den
eindruck dass es schon ernst genommen
und auch entsprechend ermittelt wird
meine haltung dass sich das teilweise
nicht mehr anzeiger hat dann eben andere
beweggründe oder vor allem andere
beweggründe
da kommt man aber fragen ob das heißt
die richtige vorgehensweise ist also es
wird ja immer aufgefordert sowas
anzuzeigen und es eben nicht stehen zu
lassen ist das nicht ein falsches signal
was ihr damit seien natürlich das ist
ein absolut falsches signal ich selbst
gebirg shops zum thema hate speech und
plädiere immer dafür und halte die leute
ein und gebe ihnen tipps und hinweise
wie sie es am besten anzeigen können
allerdings ist es so dass
kommunalpolitik in ehrenamt ist ein
ehrenamt was verdammt viel zeit frisst
man hat dann eben den job und vielleicht
auch noch ein anderes hobby
man muss unter nicht lesen man muss
interviews geben abends statt hate
speech anzuzeigen nein
und da muss man einfach schauen wie viel
zeit hat man um das entsprechend zu
machen und bei den morddrohungen zum
beispiel ist es auch ganz einfach so
dass ich zum beispiel schon angezeigt
habe immer und immer wieder aber für
mich war es eine sehr einschneidende
erfahrung beim letzten mal als ich
angezeigt habe ich kann mir wenn anonyme
telefonanrufe et cetera kommen sehr gut
einreden und das problem von mir
fernhalten indem ich mir sage okay die
entsprechende person kann auch aus
hamburg münchen oder berlin anonyme
anrufe gemacht haben
wenn ich dann dabei eine
einstellungsverfügung der
staatsanwaltschaft zugeschickt bekomme
wo drinsteht dass es in von einer
telefonzelle in bautzen in straß xy
gemacht wurde was 300 meter von dem
punkt entfernt ist wo ich zu dem
zeitpunkt der morddrohung stand lässt
sich das nicht mehr so einfach
beiseiteschieben ich sonst machen und
das hat natürlich hat es auch was mit
verdrängung zu tun entsprechende sachen
unter umständen nicht mehr anzuzeigen
was ist denn das was ihnen da helfen
würde also das kann ja im grunde nicht
sein dass man bedroht wird weil man
ihrem land ausführt für die gesellschaft
und dann einfach sagen muss ok ich muss
das jetzt irgendwie leben
ich glaube das vereinfachte
anzeigeverfahren dort in einer gewissen
weise einem schon weiterhelfen würden
aber unter umständen gerade wenn es
jetzt um bedrohungen geht es natürlich
eine sache die die polizei von amts
wegen ohnehin verfolgen muss deshalb
mache ich es auch nicht mehr öffentlich
weil die polizei sonst die
strafverfolgung anstößt und man
vorgeladen wird
es sind aber oftmals gar nicht so
konkrete bedrohung sondern so wie es im
letzten beitrag zu sehen waren eben auch
beleidigungen und verunglimpfungen das
sind keine delikte die die polizei von
amts wegen verfolgen muss sondern
sogenannte antrags delikte bei den
antrags delikten ist es dann auch so
dass die staatsanwaltschaften oftmals
einstellen aber sagen dass man den
privatklageweg beschreiten kann für den
privatklageweg benötige ich als
kommunalpolitikerin aber dann
rechtsanwalt und wenn das verfahren
eingestellt wird oder der beschuldigte
eben nicht verurteilt wird habe ich die
kosten des verfahrens unterlegt überlege
ich mir natürlich zwei mal ob ich dann
in dem fall eine privatklage weg
bestreit wo ich neben den verunglimpfen
und beleidigungen die ich sonst
zumindest so empfinden auch wenn sie
nicht abgeurteilt werden natürlich unter
umständen dann auch finanzielle
nachteile haben deshalb sollte man dann
auch ja gibt es da keine möglichkeit an
unterstützung rechtsbeistand zu kriegen
vielleicht von der stadt oder das muss
da initiativen gibt dass man sagt hier
haben wir ein topf und da könnt ihr geld
von abschöpfen wenn ihr bedroht oder
beleidigt werden
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie die anderen
politischen parteien das handhaben es
ist sicher über die parteien etwas
entsprechend zu holen da über
rechtsbeistände und so weiter aber in
der kommunalpolitik sowie ich bin auch
parteilose natürlich habe ich
rückendeckung von den grünen aber es
wird nachher auch zu einem finanziellen
problem für die parteien da müsste man
dann einfach schauen ob dort genau wie
sie eben vorgeschlagen haben dann
entsprechend von seiten der städte und
kommunen der länder oder des bundes
entsprechende finanzielle mittel zur
verfügung stehen oder dann entspricht
gesagt wird man muss nicht mehr den
privatklageweg bestreiten und da solche
dinge hier kam jetzt noch eine frage von
heike becker auf facebook die würde ich
ihnen gerne stellen wir können wir
effektiv solidarität bekunden und
unterstützen also kann man da als ganz
normaler bürger was für sie tun wo sie
sagen würden das würde mir helfen
natürlich jeder und jede kann etwas tun
indem man sich dann auch wenn
beispielsweise oftmals fängt diese hass
und hetze auf facebook in den
kommentarspalten an wenn man dort schon
mal als bürgerinnen bürger entsprechend
dann auch gegen redet und die person
entsprechend verteidigt die person
eventuell auch darauf hinweist wenn sie
es nicht mitbekommt aber auch ganz
einfach
wenn man jetzt nicht unbedingt am
stammtisch aber wenn man im alltag auch
negative kommentare über
kommunalpolitikerinnen politiker mit
bekommt oder aber auch wenn es um landes
bundespolitiker et cetera geht wir
werden jetzt hier über
kommunalpolitikerinnen vor allem aber es
betrifft eben auch politikerinnen und
politiker auf allen ebenen und ich
glaube dass wir einfach uns gegenseitig
alle helfen können wenn wir zu einer
anderen diskussionskultur kommen zu
einer diskussionskultur wohl nicht mehr
hass hitze und ausgrenzung an der
tagesordnung sind und leider oftmals
unwidersprochen bleiben sondern indem
wir in den sozialen medien im alltag bei
der familienfeier im betrieb im
sportverein eine klare haltung landtag
gegen eine klare demokratische haltung
die ohne hass und hetze auskommt das ist
ein schönes schlusswort ich danke ihnen
frau schmidt nach dresden und würde auch
hier in die kommentare noch mal genau
diesen impuls geben alles andere wird
von uns sowieso ausgeblendet und denn
nutzer sich dauerhaft daneben benehmen
werden sie auch von uns blockiert
trotzdem wünsche ich euch jetzt einen
schönen abend und sorgt vielen dank fürs
zu sehen
bis bald und falls euch das spiel
gefallen hat hier oben gibt es einen
stream mit tritt man über nazis im osten
oder hier gibt es einen stream über die
frage ist doch nur hass im netz was ist
daran so schlimm
und natürlich vergesst nicht ordentlich
6 kommentare da lassen und abonniert
unseren kanal
[Musik]